hey guys what's up this is andrew from
census.com so welcome to my
second update during my holidays i'm
still in xiaomi as you guys can see
and i'm gonna move to croatia on the
boat guys
very soon like in a couple of days i
think on saturday something like this
and i'm gonna keep updating you guys
over there
so today i wanna uh make a big update
guys on gme i haven't made
an update on the stock for i think
almost one week
and there are actually a lot of things
to say so let's get
into it
[Music]
and guys as usual let me remind you a
little bit what i was telling you in my
previous video
so basically what do we have on gamestop
so i'm gonna start on the first time
frame because this is the best time
frame to use
for technical analysis as you have
institutional clients
and big investors as well as short-term
traders
day traders calpers using this time
frame so basically the signals you're
gonna find over there
are the best signals and here the
situation
let me remind you guys we went to 480
then
we corrected strongly we bounced back to
350 and from then we had this very
complex correction that i struggled a
bit to analyze
and i don't know if you remember guys i
hear basically i lost my analysis so i
did everything again so i don't have the
same details i have before
but this was a complex correction which
is in the elliot with theory
a combination of corrective patterns so
here had zigzag
zigzag and flat then once this complex
correction was done
we started a new five waves development
i think so this is
what i label here in yellow that is
gonna go for me to 800 and the signal
was clearly given so here i told you
guys we are going there
since like 140 because i knew this
complex correction was finally done i
mean i knew you know you never know for
sure but i had a lot of signals telling
me
that it looks like this complex
correction is finished because i
labeled it very well using android waves
patterns
and when we broke this level around 200
level which was to me the major
resistance that we needed to break um to
confirm
that a new impulse impulsive move has
started we had for me the signal that
gamestop finally
started its new move up so here i told
you we're gonna go roughly to the 300
area we went to 350
and then yes that we're going to correct
to 220 200
so this is roughly what is happening so
for now for me this is all good this is
all making sense according to elliot
with theory
now what i'm trying to do guys in this
video i'm trying
here to as i did here but on a
smaller time frame when i'm zooming more
i'm trying to do same thing
here i have one that is perfectly broken
down into five waves
and i'm trying here to see what kind of
correction
i have so i'm going to use the same
method guys the same method so stay with
me
luke you just type elliott wave
principle first and press the
pdf okay you go to the false
link here and you come up with this
elliot wave course that has been written
i think 20 years ago
something like this by pressure and
frost then
here i'm looking for the double threes
and triple threes guys
you know for those for watching my video
for some time you know that i
like to use this a lot guys all right
here we are
so elliot cold sideways combinations of
corrective patterns double threes and
triple threes
so basically this are the most common
corrective patterns that
we are seeing today before we were
usually seeing
one zigzag one flat or one triangle
today
we often have especially in second waves
this kind
of combinations of corrective patterns
so the little game
consists of trying to make the price
action fit the best
with this kind of labeling so this is
what i'm trying to do here
so stay with me guys here i'm having a
zigzag abc
quite easy guys i remind you that zigzag
the c wave of a zigzag
has usually five waves i mean has always
five waves
this one two three four five is a
typical c wave then here
i'm not exactly sure to be honest it's
really really a struggle each time i
have this kind of combinations of
corrective patterns i'm i never know
guys
and i'm here i tell you everything i
never know you see if i should
make you see my a wave for example i
broke it down
into a small abc but i could do my a
wave here
i did that because this was the best way
for me to fit what is happening here
so you see each time i have some small
abcs
inside of each wave and then so i have
here
my first zigzag here my second zigzag so
a b c and
after the this one so let me get rid of
this i just wanted to show you this
guys because it's interesting so here
for example like you just saw i could do
like this
then the wave would be here and
everything would be basically
happening before what is happening now
but i did this like this guys because
i can feel that this is a triangle all
right so i'm not sure of this
yet but if i did my counting
like you saw just like this you know so
everything
is one step before then my triangle
would be here
okay let me change the color of this and
i don't like it because here i have one
reaction
one one reaction but here we don't go to
this level
so maybe if we go there maybe i would
change my labeling but for now this is
the best way for me to see the price
action
and what is left for me a b c
d so starting we're gonna go to 220
then correct one more time to 2010 and
then finally
start the third wave of the third wave
which as usual guys is going to be very
impulsive and it's going to
take back some major level now something
i wanted to show you guys do you
remember that i'm
always telling you that once a
resistance is broken
it's usually re-tested so the breakout
level here
guys you can see so as usual during the
breakout look
very strong volumes here all right so it
was the first time for a very long time
we didn't have this kind of volume so
this is confirming you can see here guys
on the hourly timeframe
that the volume happened here during the
breakout at
roughly 198 level right
and then where are the strong volume
kicking
again look on the hourly here it's the
strongest
volume we never had on the hourly
timeframe
since a very long time so this is good
and this is happening where i guess
at the breakout level at 198.
it didn't happen here okay we didn't
have the strong volumes but
they're starting to kick in you can see
guys
so this is just a little reminder that
you know patience
often pays out in trading because a lot
of you
may be fomo here and you go to some high
levels
it's fine i think we're gonna go higher
but once again
when the breakout occurs it's usually
retested so you have time yes and this
is something that i like to repeat
because this is
one of the keys to succeed in in
training guys you need to be patient
and to really enter your trades at the
best levels
it's very hard even for me not too
formal sometimes you know i see a
breakout i'm like all right i want to
buy it i want to get in this trade
because i know it's going to grow higher
and i don't want to miss it
true but keep in mind that ninety
percent of the time the breakout levels
are retested
so here you had two more opportunities
to enter this trade at the very good
level
you had on the 25th of may so
once again i repeat so my view is we go
here
so we we complete this the first wave we
are doing here a corrective wave
ah yeah and something else very
interesting i wanted to show you guys
look when you look at the themes
so i remind you what i'm always telling
you just by looking at the field if you
don't know where to put your trend lines
guys
so basically every move likes to retrace
i mean second waves light retrace to the
50
or 61.8 percent field retracement
so this is 240 and 215 between the 61.8
and the 78.6
retracement level this is a gray area
where basically
you might reconsider your analysis you
know basically it means that the bears
are strong and here let's be honest the
bells are stronger compared to this
first wave they put
the price down quite a lot compared for
example to amc
where i remind you guys we are in the
false wave and we trade
around the 38.2 retracement of the
third wave so this is very bullish here
we don't have the same bullishness guys
this is weaker
definitely but you know
when i'm in this situation you know i
ask myself
are you sure this is actually bullish
so of course i can't be sure but what is
here for me very bullish
is that this is the second wave here is
very messy
you know once again this is not
impulsive you know it's not a beautiful
one two three four five
it's something messy it's something that
is corrective
so once you know and once again i can
label it quite
well using elliot wave patterns which is
actually
confirming to me that this is corrective
so
if this is corrective i know that the
first wave was
definitely motive and that the third
wave is coming you see the reasoning
when something is messy and not clean
then you know it's correct then you know
that
the market is going to reverse soon and
that this is not
the longer term direction so here the
longer term direction is bullish
this is why the second wave is correct
one more thing i
like to talk about divergences i'm
looking for divergences all the time
guys
and when i spot one i tell you so here i
remind you on the hourly timeframe we
had one here
so here market making low lows and
during the same time as you can see
the maxi was making higher lows all
right it's just over here
it's this one all right the regular
bullish divergence market making
lower lows and during the same time the
macd going higher so basically the
momentum is with us
and the bears are making you know a
lower low but not with the same
intensity not just the same strengths as
they used to
so the momentum is actually shifting and
this means that the reversal is to come
so we still have this english hidden
dimensions that is playing out here
and i don't see anything else here so
i repeat guys what is my view what did i
tell you everything so i talked about
the fibs
moving averages the last thing guys so i
don't i don't have much to say here
regarding moving averages i don't find
on any time frame something that is
fitting well the best i can find guys
is on the daily time frame on the daily
time frame i have the 50 period
moving average this one guys in purple
that is giving me the best reactions all
right and that is supporting the price
you can see it's supporting here here
it's you know fake out
kind of here supporting the price
supporting the price supporting the
price
and here supporting the price again so
basically
my level is you know this moving average
that is
coming close to my triangle so the
levels to which are for me on the short
term two
or seven then two or three and 197
those three levels if we go through
those levels on the downside it is
not good guys it's not gonna happen i
almost can guarantee it because i have
all the signals that
look good to me but if it happens
careful careful
it means the bears are in control for
now they are not
so and of course i remind you guys that
my target is 800 and i found this level
using fib projections so i'm projecting
the roof here i'm taking the first wave
and i'm playing at the bottom of the
second wave 830 it really depends
where i start my first wave i need to go
to 480 look on the right of the screen
all right so somewhere here so 815 you
know it's just an area of course you
can't be very precise when you do that
long-term projections but the 800 level
is probably going to be the level we're
going to reach before some
longer and deeper correction so guys
that's it for me i hope you enjoyed this
video and if you did
please don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button so you're gonna be
the first to know when i upload anything
new and stay close to shore see you guys